goddamn creep recently I watched a movie
called st. Vincent which has Bill
Mariana and he plays this really just
mean old man living in Brooklyn
Lissa McCarthy moves in next to him I
with the Sun and she's single mom
through trials and tribulations of a
single mother just leave her son with
Bill and through the unadulterated pure
joy of the child
Bill Murray learns to lighten up it's a
documentary the movie was great and
sweet and cute and funny and made me
think oh yeah
sometimes looking at Bill Murray is like
looking into a mirror because sometimes
I am cranky I was gonna try and quantify
it for you but just get me pissed off I
think it's okay to be cranky and I think
it's okay to be around cranky people I
think it just requires delicate care
like an old dove you just requires
delicate care not the soap so today I
thought I would tell you three ways that
you can handle being around a cranky
person and three ways that you can
handle being a cranky person there are
three ways you can handle a cranky
person number one opposite of a reality
makeover program don't try to change
them in their mind all of their thoughts
and feelings are the only correct
thoughts and feelings that exist like an
overweight person that has wedged
themselves into that seat on the roller
coaster they are not budging it's a
waste of your beautiful smelling breath
to try and get them to feel otherwise
cranky people take you trying to make
them feel better as an attack cranky
people hate people who try have you ever
read a youtube comment instead try to
direct your energy into brushing your
teeth because that whole beautiful
breath comment I just said was a lie
number two like the NASA space program
to an astronaut Gale in space both
physical and mental space cranky people
seem to have a seemingly endless pool of
burning negativity they're like an
invisible fence and you're like a
happy-go-lucky three-legged bug with no
boundaries it's not going to end well
you're gonna end up with two legs and
trust issues and number three like Rose
to Jack on the Titanic don't let them
bring you down with them Rose was a true
example of a survivor who got a lot of
help from a selfless human and exploited
it for her own personal breathing game a
cranky person can be a lot like the
Ebola virus politically very polarizing
and socially very contagious stay away
focus on your positives or positive
activities positive friends positive
pregnancy test results that you're
positive friend just told you about for
her good for her now here are three
clips for being a cranky person because
it happens and if you don't think it'll
happen to you you can go eat dog [ __ ]
maybe that's why your breath is bad
number one like me on the weekends try
to stay away from social situations as a
cranky person you are a whirling dervish
of emotions and rage and skewed
viewpoints on the world at large the
last thing you need is to get a little
tipsy on a Friday night and ask your
friend Meghan if what she's looking for
and all those instagrams where she's
looking off camera these are father's
approval unlike a tattoo artist try not
to cause permanent damage yeah that
person might tell you that they really
want the flower with the fetus in it
under the rainbow but don't give it to
them number two like a Please Touch
Museum try to be okay feeling this
feeling cranky is an emotion and if
you're feeling emotions congratulations
you're not a robot and if you are a
robot that can feel emotion
cool job Japan feeling cranky or
frustrated if harnessed over time can
lead to inspiration and more positive
thinking how I say it is that hopefully
eventually you'll get so cranky that you
hate yourself so much that you have
nothing better to do than make a change
the biggest loser and if you get stuck
in the cranky world and never make a
positive change I don't really have
anything to say to you because you're
probably not watching this video because
it already pissed you off so much
and number three like a vegan central
air unit virus in a healthy way try to
use things other than people's emotions
and personal insecurities to get out to
your negative energy
maybe exercise maybe create something
that is art maybe watch something
inspiring on YouTube and then maybe
subscribe to that person because they're
so good at YouTube and then when you're
done subscribing to Tyler Oakley please
subscribe to me there you go there are
my three tips for being a cranky person
and three tips for handling cranky
people I hope that this helped if it
didn't help I don't know don't forget to
subscribe if you enjoyed this video and
like it with this signal not just like
this by like clicking the button that
gives a signal if you liked it and go
watch st. Vincent if you liked movies
that have heart and sharp sharp pain